well we were just talking about the
environment and we're likely to hear
plenty more about it in the next couple
of weeks because extinction rebellion
the movement campaign to raise awareness
of climate and the ecological decline of
planning two weeks of direct action in
London and other cities around the world
and joining us now are savannah Lovelock
and Sarah Lennon both extinction
rebellion activists thank you for being
on the show
so what should we be expecting there
next week okay so next week we're
actually taking rebellion to the
government and we're actually going to
be in Westminster and we're going to be
outside government departments asking
where is their plan Parliament declared
a climate emergency on the 1st of May
and now we need a plan to deal with it
so where's the plan if you're talking
that your focus is gonna be around
Westminster spokesperson told a press
conference this week we're going to
blockade and shut down every single Road
going into Westminster now there's a
major hospitals in there on Westminster
Bridge are you worried about how it
could impact patients or families trying
to visit you know their loved ones well
I think it's about this understanding of
the wider perspective and we have people
on the bridges you can have
conversations that people are trying to
get there and is potential of you know
if people really really need to get
there but letting them through possibly
in that conversation but it's this wider
perspective of you know like what is
coming and the risks we have to take and
the emergency that is coming and that we
have to have our voices heard and we're
really really sorry we don't want to be
doing it but we're running out of time
and this is what we have to do right now
because you can't you can't guarantee
you can you that there won't be
disruption that emergency vehicles that
ambulances might not go to get to that
hospital okay so there absolutely is
going to be disruption there's
disruption coming whether we take to the
streets or not you could just look at
the rain that happened this morning huge
disruption across the roads I'm talking
about specific it will be disruption
assessed in terms of blue lights
ambulances with blue lights can
guarantee people will get out of the way
for ambulances with blue lights and also
discussions with the police they know
what we're doing and so alternative
routes can be put in place but if an
ambulance with blue lights turns up at
any roadblock with extinction rebellion
activists
we will get out of their way there is
absolutely no doubt about what about
families as well because we have had
cases haven't we I remember back in July
someone saying that he knew missed being
at his father's bedside when he died in
Bristol yeah and that's really really
unfortunate and it's totally
heartbreaking and when you think about
it makes you feel absolutely dreadful so
there is no way that we want to be doing
this we've been forced into this
position by the lack of action from
governments for the last 30 years and
what is coming change is coming to us
whether we like it or not the pain and
anguish that that man suffered been
unable to say goodbye to his father is
the pain and anguish we are suffering
right now as we look at the future of
our children because it's very very
grave we're looking it's calm and I know
that I know I'm not trying to say that
it's not deeply concerning the
environment but his very specific pain
about not seeing his father he might not
really think that was comparable I and I
totally understand that but what we are
having to do is shift the conversation
from us as individuals as we live out
our individual lives to looking at that
mass death mass famine and starvation
like the loss of future for all of our
children and our governments are not
addressing it so we have tried we've
marched we've been members of the Green
Party we've passed motions in Council
and there has been no action and it's
only when we've taken to the streets and
caused this disruption that you asked us
on to this program you asked us to come
and speak you know and so I do not want
to be doing this I do know what to be
upset in people's lives but life on
Earth is dying our children's future is
disappearing in front of our faces in
front of our you know our very eyes so
unless we disrupt nothing happens this
disruption is caused by the people but
not them not taking action so if you
want ask your type of questions you need
to ask them what would be a victory then
what would be something that we you
could say is a victory you're going to
call off a destruction that's enough a
victory would be the leader of the
government the opposition parties in
coming together and accepting to go
through Parliament
based on our three demands that they
will tell the truth about the emergency
we are facing life on earth is dying
that they will aim for the most extreme
carbon reduction target possible zero
carbon by 2025 and then to enable it to
happen to give legitimacy to those asks
we have a citizen's assembly we upgrade
our democracy we've seen it failing with
brexit we upgrade our democracy so that
those plans can pass and we have a
citizen's assembly to do it because if
we don't do that we don't have a future
it's that simple it's it's so great
billions of people are going to die I
can't believe I'm saying this you know
look I look around me but all this
electricity I came in an electric car I
went through London and yet we are
facing a catastrophe and we need to act
I mean it's interesting when you're
talking there about one of the things
being this very very ambitious target to
bring down those emissions I mean we're
going to need some pretty radical
policies aren't we if we're gonna get
there and it's gonna be personal
sacrifices as well it's not I mean is it
acceptable as trying to talk a little
bit to Sean Barie about some of these
things you know do we need to think
about whether we're eating me do we need
to think about a complete ban on cars do
we need to think about fast fashion what
what are the radical things that you
think we need to change now and I think
it's an understanding of like what we
personally take in terms of the meat ban
and stuff like that we need to eat
locally if we can't eat meat then we
have to eat local you have to eat within
our means and it's understanding that we
are continuously taking more resources
and we can so there needs to be more of
an education about what we need to take
and then this is what a kind of thing
like assembly can look at in terms of
what legislation needs to be put down
because it's so obvious our government
can absolutely not do this they've had
30 years 30 years to do this and there's
still nothing so this is why we need a
citizen's assembly to come up with these
legislations and took this all-star I
mean is there anything that you have
wrestled with personally I mean oh no
that we could all do more in our lives
couldn't we Beck you know if you've got
like you know primer addiction or like
is it hard to kind of give up that
flight to you know America or to Europe
what are the difficult things it is very
hard to step out of the society that
that you're living within it's very hard
to separate yourself from your friends
and your family whoo-hoo
well be catching flights who you know
eating roast dinners every Sunday you
know if you separate yourself you then
become different and extreme and why
would people listen to you when you know
you're some kind of New Age Puritan and
so that that's a huge struggle when you
educate yourself about the climate you
do tend to separate yourself do your
techniques you stop fish on I don't know
you know but it's not based on what you
have to do as an individual we are going
to have to change but we need to change
our system we can't do it through
individual choice and and you asked what
kind of extreme action is needed do have
a historical precedence on this we
mobilized for war in 1939 we made huge
changes across our society but we did it
and we brought people together about
what you knew you think we need them
that is absolutely as serious as that
yeah it's as serious as that you know
I'm just turned 20 I've had to defer
from University I work with young people
because I'm from exile youth and you
know I'm in rooms these 14 year-olds you
know who are in tears because of this
they are in a world right there in a
city and they're constantly surrounded
by the fact of those people who will not
even understand the role they are
playing in fact that these kids futures
are being ripped away you know they are
being told that they're gonna die and
people are saying no no it's fine you
know do your recycling you know be fine
it's just absolute really I just want to
end because I put out on Twitter that I
was gonna be talking to you and I got I
have to say a pretty overwhelming
response to questions I should ask there
were more than 400 replies I just want
to show you a bit of a flavor of what
some of those questions were if they
believe the world will end in 12 years
how come they have pensions actually I
don't do do they conduct any sort of
equality impact assessment as to who is
adversely affected by their demos last
time seem like working-class people most
affected while middle-class protectors
protesters skateboarders with the police
and then just finally how does stopping
people getting to work or hospital
appointments help the environment are
you worried that by this disruptive
action you might be harming the cause
turning people against you so we spent
in the environmental movement we've
spent 30 years behaving ourselves and
using the systems there to request our
government to change and nothing has
happened in fact what has happened is
our co2 emissions have increased and
they've and they're getting faster and
faster right no tune has ever lived in
the planet we now live in a 415 parts
per million that was three million years
ago we were not alive then we're walking
out into an unknown future and what has
worked if the environment is now the
third most important issue of public
concern and that is because we took to
the streets and we demonstrated and we
caused mass disruption nothing else has
worked so yes I understand
people are going to be adversely
impacted and some people are going to be
impacted more than others but the change
that is coming what is going to happen
is going to it there is no escape for
anybody the famine the grief the war is
going to impact on all of us okay and
something else is taking consideration
with this is you know some things may
not reached our country yet but what is
happening in other countries in the
global South in the majority world is
absolutely horrific and that we cannot
stand here as one of the worst countries
you know in terms of producing this
consumerism which affects these other
countries and not do anything it's
absolutely ridiculous and the fact you
know people have to understand what it
is to be a global citizen and that we
all have responsibility you know
individually and within our communities
to understand the place we hold within
the entire planet and the responsibility
we have to act on that okay thank you
both I just I just want sex and violence
I know but it's you know it is an
emergency and we get ten minutes but
Savannah's so right about that nobody is
in the Bahamas anymore but it has been
devastated because of our climate
breakdown and you know that's what we
should be looking at it's here and now
okay thank you both very much for being
on the show this morning thank you